لكن هذا سؤال مهم نطرحه على ضيفنا الدكتور
التعاني من واشنطن مساله ديمقراطيه
اسرائيل هذه نظرا لان فيها انتخابات هل ما
زالت قادره على تسويق فكره قتل الاف
المدنيين و عشرات الالاف من المدنيين
والاف الاطفال وما الى
ذلك نعم انا برايي ان الفشل المتدحرج
لدوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وصمود شعبنا
الاسطوري الحقيقه في في غزه بالرغم من
كميه القتل الغير مس بوقه وعمليات التطهير
العرقي وال القتل الجماعي الذي تمارسه
دوله الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فهذا صمود فعلا يعني ترفع له
القبعه ولكن هذا يعني هذه الخسائر الكبيره
جدا بالارواح بكل اسف ادت الى
ان كان هناك تردد عند حتى من بين
شباب الجاليات اليهوديه في الولايات
المتحده الذين تربوا معظمهم على حب دوله
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعلى انها معجزه
الذين صنعوا من الصحراء خضره وما الى ذلك
وهم كانوا صهاينه بكثير منهم نرى ان هذا
صار في انقلاب انقلاب كبير يعني رايناه لم
نرى مثل هذا الحراك الجامع على مستوى
الجامعات في الولايات المتحده منذ حرب
فيتنام منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي لم يكن
هناك حراك بمعنى في كل الولايات المتحده
في كل
ال الولايات المختلفه وهذا الحراك مؤيد ل
الفلسطيني بمعظمه فهذا الانقلاب برايي
ينسحب ايضا على عدد كبير من شرائح مختلفه
من الشعب الامريكي الاتحادات العماليه
المختلفه تطالب بوقف اطلاق النار الان
البعض يطالب بان يكون هنا محاكمات على
جرائم الحرب وال يعني نكاد نرى هذه
الابتسامه الع على وجوه النشطاء في
الولايات المتحده بسبب ان باختصار تقول ان
فكره ديمقراطيه اسرائيل ب بين قوسين لم
تعد قادره على ابتزاز المجتمع الامريكي
ولم تعد قادره على استجداء المواقف التي
تغض من خلالها يغض من خلال العالم الطرف
عن الممارسات التي تحدث الان